the crown must win Queen Elizabeth is
the second longest reigning British
monarch she has been rocking that crown
for 66 years and she's still going
strong but all rains come to an end
so we're breaking down exactly who is in
line to take over the throne in 1952
then 25-year old Elizabeth assumed royal
duties when her father King George the
6th unexpectedly fell ill and died but
Elizabeth was never actually expected to
become Queen you see her uncle Prince
Edward inherited the throne from King
George the fifth and was expected to
marry and have kids of his own which
would have knocked Elizabeth
down in the line of succession once you
put it on it stays I mean it just drains
itself but in 1936 when Liz was just 10
there was a dramatic royal scandal and
word abdicated the throne after 11
months tameria's divorced lover American
socialite Wallis Simpson marking the
first voluntary British abdication in
1,000 years
beloved common man may marry for love
why not me give you a common man and
what basis could you possibly claim to
be king and Elizabeth's dad George
reluctantly took over as king making her
the heir apparent
but who will assume the crown after the
92 year old Queen dies that'd be her
eldest son Charles Prince of Wales the
question is Willy's second wife Camilla
Duchess of Cornwall become Queen their
relationship has been pretty
controversial since it played a big role
in the breakdown of Charles's first
marriage to the late Princess Diana
so while Camilla will legally be
Charles's Queen it's likely she will
hold the title of Princess consort know
something don't lie awake waiting or
hoping for it because it sadly means
that my my family had moved on and I
don't want that next in line is
Charles's eldest son and Queen
Elizabeth's grandson Prince William Duke
of Cambridge
now William's younger brother Prince
Harry was one third in line to the
throne but that all changed in 2013 when
willing Kate welcomed their first child
Prince George
you know George there'll be a time in a
place two supreme - a job and yeah I
understand how he fits in in the world
so George's position to take over as
king after William then Harry got
demoted again in 2015 when his knees
Princess Charlotte was born the now
three year old is currently fourth in
line to the crown meanwhile Harry took
another step down with the birth of
willing Kate third child in April Prince
Louie is fifth in line and will remain
there thanks to the 2013 succession of
the crown act you see prior to this law
boys would overtake their older sisters
in line to the throne shut up but now
four males born after October 28 2011
it's against the law so Charlotte will
keep her fourth place status thanks to
all the Cambridge kids our favorite
ginger is now sixth in line to the
throne so is there a chance he'll ever
be king
on October 15th Harry and wife Megan
Duchess of Sussex announced they're
expecting their first child in each
other it's a new chapter right be it a
boy or a girl Harry and Megan's child
will hold the seventh position in line
of course the chance of one day becoming
king or queen is never out of the
question
Queen Victoria was born fifth in line to
succeed her grandfather King George the
third sadly her father died shortly
after her birth and she became heir to
the throne because the three uncles
ahead of her had no legitimate surviving
children but we want to know what type
of King do you think Prince Charles will
be
[Music]